hello and welcome to kubernetes
interview questions now the great thing
about being at kubernetes expert is that
there is a growing market for people
wanting to hire you and you're gonna get
asked a lot of questions in this video
we're gonna take you through the 13 most
common questions that you are likely to
be asked in a Cuban eighties interview
as always if you like this video we have
the subscribe button below and then the
like button that will notify you of all
new videos as they get submitted also if
you have any questions feel free to post
those into the questions below
and we'll get back to you with answers
with trained answer as many questions as
possible so without any more hesitation
let's jump into some of the popular
interview questions that you're gonna
get asked we're gonna break up the
interview questions into three
categories it's going to be beginner
intermediate and advanced the beginner
questions are really going to cover
about three-quarters of the questions
that we're going to ask here and then
the intermediate and advanced will
finalize out the will fish out the final
quarter and and the reason is is that
quite typically most interviews you'll
be asked you know intermediate to
beginner level questions mainly beginner
level questions just so you can
demonstrate your understanding of
kubernetes and then there's always one
advanced question that gets thrown out
just to make sure that you really do
know what you're talking about and
you've done at least one or two
kubernetes environment setups to be able
to validate your experience so let's
kind of jump into that first section
which is you know why's kubernetes
widely used and your answer to this
really comes into the fact that
kubernetes is widely used because of
three distinct areas one is that
kubernetes is an open source platform
that is readily available for the
management of containers and allows you
to manage the deployment scaling and
management of those containers and so
the first area is that it allows you for
easy deployment of your containers the
ability to scale effectively within
communities not just vertically but
horizontally for your containers and
then finally the kubernetes environment
itself was really designed to make it
easy to manage
containers in small parts other key
areas of why kubernetes is popular is
that kubernetes is the single largest
open source project out there since its
launch in 2014 is just grown in leaps
and bounds around that project there is
just a huge community both an online and
physical community there are just a
large number of online groups that are
supporting kubernetes and allow you to
get fast access to information but in
addition to that there are also a lot of
local meetup groups that cover
specifically kubernetes weather as part
of a DevOps group or as part of a
dedicated kubernetes group the actual
environment itself is a really robust
way of being able to manage your
containers containers are becoming the
most popular way of being able to deploy
cloud based applications kubernetes is
an effective and persistent storage
environment so kubernetes is also able
to effectively manage persistent storage
whether it's local storage as a SSD
drive or a local hard drive or whether
it's cloud based storage and because of
the way that kubernetes is architecture
it's really designed for the cloud from
the ground up so it's a great way to get
started in building out your cloud
solutions and then finally the actual
tools within kubernetes are designed to
help them manage the health and
monitoring of the environments itself so
what is Google container engine so the
Google container engine is another open
source solution but it's designed for
managing the docket containers and
clusters and so kubernetes is a
container management solution and docker
is the most popular container solution
out there and this is just a way of
being able to bring the to effectively
within to each other so that you can
have docker containers manage the
application and then kubernetes match
the scale of your applications as
they're vertically and horizontally
scaled across your network so what is
difference between kubernetes and dock
and this is important because kubernetes
and are often dropped in the same
sentence and there's a lot of people
that get confused between the two so
fundamentally kubernetes is about taking
pods which contain containers which have
applique
and deploying them at scale across a
cloud network docker is the container
solution itself so the actual
application itself is put into the
docker container because of this
difference kubernetes is designed for
auto scaling is highly available whereas
docker simply isn't because it doesn't
have to worry about that within the
container itself the kubernetes
environment will check for liveness and
readiness of the health of the entire
infrastructure whereas with docker is
just really going to check the services
that are coming in and out of the actual
application itself within the container
kubernetes is complicated to set up it
really is just simply complicated set up
and what you'll find is a lot of cloud
services what you do the set up for you
whereas docker is very easy to set up
the as you would expect with the
tolerance ratio there is high fault
tolerance river kubernetes whereas with
docker is low fault tolerance again this
is fundamental in the two different
types of strategy that kubernetes and
docker have they're both connected
tightly with each other but they both do
different things so what are the notable
features of kubernetes and one is the
ability to do container bounds
kubernetes always knows where to place a
container within its entire network
within the pods and with his
infrastructure the services are managed
for security network and storage it is
self monitoring so it goes in and is
able to check its own nodes for health
and the containers within the nodes so
it makes sure that the applications are
always running effectively you can do
the scaling effectively both vertically
and horizontally within kubernetes the
solution is open source so there's no
actual fee for the actual kubernetes
service itself and kubernetes allows for
storage orchestration what does they
mean by storage orchestration storage
orchestration is that you are able to
access and share either local storage
such as a hard drive or SSD drive or a
cloud-based drive and my preference is
always to go with cloud-based Drive
because then you're really positioning
your solution to be a true cloud-based
application so what are the main
advantages of kubernetes where you get
automatic rollback for changes that go
wrong the you're able to automate a lot
of the process
that would have been manual processes
previously you're able to scale the
resources both vertically and
horizontally easily and quickly and then
these three areas the role bank
automating role bank automating services
and being able to scale indirectly
allows you to save money by reducing the
amount of time and people working on
your operations environment so let's
break out the architecture of kubernetes
so you're gonna be explained us to
explain how is kubernetes architecture
structured and there are three key areas
there's the application layer there's
kubernetes layer and then there's the
infrastructure layer we're gonna start
off with the infrastructure layer so the
infrastructure layer is our base layer
and this is where you're where you make
your clusters for your collections of
storage and networking resources within
kubernetes and this is where you would
have if your databases are your data
stored locally on a hard drive or in the
cloud
your core network and the VMS that you'd
be building out your infrastructure on
these allow you to group many Sheen's
together into a single unit so that
you're able to scale up and down very
easily to meet customer demand so let's
talk about the middle layer which is the
kubernetes layer now so if we're looking
at our architecture for our kubernetes
layer it's really broken down for the
the core operating system the docker
container environment and the kubernetes
code itself and this is where you're
able to take machines and pull them
together as a cluster so that they work
within that kubernetes system you have a
master controller within kubernetes that
actually then we'll go ahead and manage
the scheduler control manager of the API
server and then you'll be able to
cluster all of these communities
together so that they're all working and
processing as one single unit and then
finally let's look at the application
layer where you actually have your apps
and so the application layer where you
have your pool and your services you
know kubernetes will use api to connect
in and out of this layer it's to run
your applications within containers and
you use instructions that are written in
yellow or JSON to actually set up those
containers and uhm to have the
running on a plan that examines these
instructions so it keeps the entire
environment healthy a VI ecosystem is
used to interact with the class sir it's
so you don't have to do that by yourself
so make sure that you're referencing
that the api's are secured and
connecting in and out of the system and
so you have your schedule and Control
Manager actually from the kubernetes
environment doing the hard work and then
the workers themselves execute the
commands that coming from kubernetes so
you will be asked to kind of dig into
some of the key areas such as explaining
the master node and listing its
components so the master node is
comprised of four key components there's
the cluster store the controller manager
the scheduler and the API server so four
key point components remember four
fingers four components and then you're
gonna be asked to maybe dig deeper into
what is a cluster within kubernetes and
so a customer is really combination of
resources such as machines that into a
single node and then those nodes are
pulled together and work as a single
cluster as a whole kubernetes will work
with that whole cluster and then once
you're actually working with that whole
cluster if a node fails or needs to be
removed kubernetes is able to do that
quickly and effectively so let's talk a
little bit about what are the different
types of controllers in kubernetes and
there are five types of control manager
you have the node controller the service
account the token control the endpoint
controller and the replication
controller and so the node controller
controls and handles the node in the
system the service account enables
access controls in the system the token
controller cleans up any tokens for
non-existent service accounts the
endpoint control adjoins services in
pods to the endpoint objects and the
replication controller manages the pod
lifecycle so what is the role of the
cloud controller manager within this
environment and so the role the Cloud
Control Manager is really to help manage
persistent storage and so persistent
storage is storage that's neither local
storage to the physical machine such as
an SSD or hard drive or cloud-based
store
rich and this allows the storage to be
shared across the entire network what is
the role of the cube API server and the
cube scheduler so the cube API server is
principal for the establishing of
communication between the Kuban etting
nodes and the master components and and
it does this through the through api's
the api themselves are all commands that
are rest-based commands and implements
an interface which means different tools
and libraries can communicate
effectively with each other so what is
the role of the cube api server and the
cubes scheduler so the cubes capture
actually does the distribution of work
across the entire infrastructure to the
actual llamó scripts that you've written
are executed appropriately at the right
time so you're gonna be asked to explain
persistent volumes in kubernetes so a
persistent volume is just a place where
you can store data again this can be
local data as in a hard drive local to
the physical machine or it can be
cloud-based data so what is a cube let
and a cube proxy so a cube light is a
service responsible for conveying
information to and from the control plan
it's so the process and the kou proxy
itself is responsible the maintaining
the work and the standards within the
nodes server in addition every node in
the cluster runs a simple network proxy
and queue proxy routes request to the
correct container in that node in
addition you'll have some basic and
primitive load balancing and management
of the node from the proxy itself and
there's additional layers of management
that get done outside of the proxy but
the proxy is also there to help do some
localized load management so what is
cube ctso cube CTL is your command line
or terminal window interface that allows
you to execute commands and later in
this video we'll actually go through
some of those commands etcd is the store
that configures the details and
essential values such as key value pairs
that are distributed across your entire
network it also manages the network
rules and the post forwarding of
activity so what are the disadvantages
of kubernetes well the first is it's
really hard to install and configure and
this is why Asia and many cloud service
such as Google cloud will actually do
the installation and configuration of
kubernetes for you it does take a long
time to get up and running with
kubernetes not so much for the actual
software but your own experience of
being able to use kubernetes it is not
simple to manage the service you
actually have to have a lot of
experience and this is why people get
paid a lot for kubernetes skills it's a
difficult environment to get up and
running and be effective in that
management again kubernetes is just not
an easy platform to learn it takes a lot
of time and effort and one of the
disadvantages is that while kubernetes
itself is free because it is an open
source project getting the people who
are skilled you to using cuba Nettie's
is expensive alright so those were kind
of the introductory questions that you
can expect to be asked in your interview
the next set of questions are really
going to be on an intermediate and
advanced level and these are the
questions that will be thrown out you
know you see these as being that the
trick questions which are really there
to test that you have the skill set to
be able to implement and manage
kubernetes within a company so what
happens if a master node fails what
happens if a worker node fails
how would kubernetes manage that well
kubernetes is really designed for this
kind of scenario and so you can actually
look at it and the response would be is
that the pod itself does not get
affected kubernetes will actually
respond and fix the the failed node
whether it is needs to be repaired
whether there needs to be restarted or
needs to be replaced so what is a
service role in kubernetes so a service
role is an abstraction for all of the
pods it provides a virtual IP address
and it allows clients to connect to
containers running in the pods using
that virtual IP address and the command
that you would use to get that we would
use some of these cube CTO commands it's
quite a simple one it's cube CTL gets
services and you get a full less than of
all the services that are available so
how do I do a role Bank in deployment
and so there's a couple of ways you can
do the rollback and the first is if you
want to see the rollouts history
deployments you would write cubes ETL
rollout history deployment and then in
square brackets deploy
if you want to just restore to the
previous rollout the command would be
cube CTL rollout undo deployment and
then in square brackets deployment and
that would take you back to the previous
deployment so what is an ingress
controller so the ingress controller
really is a pod that manages that
inbound traffic and a prominent feature
that traffic is that it is secured with
an SSL termination and so what we're
gonna do to now address some of the key
ways in which you can provide API
security zone cuban IDs and we have
eight of those so the first four are
implementing TR TLS for your security
the second would be api authentication
the third is to make the Cubist
protection the cublas protected via
authorization mode equals webhook
command the fourth is to monitor our BAC
failures the fifth is to remove those
default service account permissions six
would be to filter egress to cloud API
metadata API the seventh is to use pot
security policy to restrict container
policies and protect the node and the
eighth and final is to keep the cube at
the latest version alright let's go into
some of the more advanced commands and
so the advanced questions you're gonna
get are gonna be commands that you're
gonna be asked to write now my advice
for you for these questions is to make
sure that you have some of these basic
commands memorized they don't have to be
perfect when you're in the interview
environment but it's good to be able to
get up to a whiteboard and actually
write out what these commands are just
so you can actually demonstrate that you
know what the commands are the interview
isn't gonna ask you questions on how
would you apply kubernetes to the
company that you're being hired for
because you simply don't have that
knowledge but they do want to be able to
see clearly that you understand the
commands and terminal window
instructions that will be able to
demonstrate how you would actually go in
and access some of that information so
from the first questions you might be
asked is how do you package coop
these applications and so you would use
the package manager within Cuba Nettie's
to be able to manage the and configure
and deploy applications into your
cluster and so here we have the the helm
command that you would use so what are
in it containers and in each container
gets executed for any other containers
can run on the pod and so you want to be
able to illustrate what the init
instructions would look like and here we
have an example and I would again use
this example and maybe memorize it for
when you have this question come up in
your interview so what is the difference
between a config map and a secret and
these are more fundamental so it config
map just has the instructions that are
clearly available in plain tanks on what
the cube is supposed to do whereas the
secrets are actually encrypted and these
are like passwords and other sensitive
data that you don't want to have easily
available these are encrypted
information have to be decrypted to
access the content so if a note is
tainted is there a way to schedule the
pods to that note and the answer is no
there isn't and so what you have to do
then is schedule the pod to be fixed and
so that schedule the pod to fix the
tainted node to allow for toleration to
that and we have here the example code
that you would use to do that so how do
you deploy a feature with zero downtime
in kubernetes well kubernetes is
designed to be able to roll out
applications with zero downtime and here
we have four examples using the rolling
update as a strategy for zero downtime
deployments in kubernetes again memorize
one of these so you can actually
illustrate how you use rollout to be
able to deploy a zero downtime solution
so how do you monitor a pod that is
always running and so to do that you use
the liveness probe to check the health
of the application within the pod and
see whether or not there are any
failures or whether or not the pod
itself needs to be restarted so how do
you drain traffic from pod during a
maintenance so again this is a simple
command for you to remember but to be
to drain an application so that it's
easy for you to be able to do
maintenance on the application you would
use the cube CTL drain and then in
square brackets the node name and that
would then temporarily drain that
particular pod so you can actually do
maintenance on it what you have to then
and this would probably give you bonus
points with your're in an interview is
then reference the uncoordinated
node itself so that the potty itself can
come back up into life and work as a
fully functioning solution so to be able
to tie services to a partner to a set of
pods you say you can apply labels to the
actual parts themselves and then use the
labels as selectors to be able to glue
services to that part and again we have
here an example of how you'd actually do
that and again this is some one of those
where you can pretty one be asked to
write this out but it'd be good to have
this memorized how'd you get all pods on
a node and so the following command will
actually go ahead and bring all the pods
into a kubernetes cluster this is quite
a lengthy and you know maybe you want to
like talk to how this would be done but
we have the instructions and how to do
that right here and the important part
is to make sure that you are when you're
talking about the node name that you
reference to whoever you're interviewing
that you would what you would switch out
to reference the actual nodes that
you're trying to pull together into the
kubernetes cluster so how do pods mount
NFS volumes and so in these examples
here we actually define the NFS server
and then the pod and how you'd actually
mount two together and again what you
want to be able to do is illustrate why
you would use Y ammo and how you'd
actually then point to specific IP
addresses within your kubernetes
environment within either the production
or test environments to be able to
illustrate how you would mount out those
NFS volumes so hopefully these 30
questions really give you the
information that you need to be
successful when you're interviewing for
a position or a role responsible for
kubernetes management within the
operations environment on a DevOps team
if you have any questions please
personally
we're always answering those questions
and we get to them as quickly as we can
if you liked the video certainly go
ahead and share this but also hit the
subscribe button and the like button the
subscribe button will just give you more
of these videos and that the the like
button will alert you about new videos
as they come out good luck in your
interview
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos Dinard up and get certified click
here